More specifically, the actual OOA technique to apply is the following.
First off, obtain or prepare a textual description of a problem.
Underline in your textual description all the nouns.
Organize the nouns into groups to become candidate classes,
then underline all the adjectives.
Assign the adjectives as attributes of the candidate classes.
Then, underline the verbs, differentiating action verbs from stative verbs.
Assign the action verbs as operations of classes,
and assign the stative verbs as attributes of classes or relationships.
Sounds simple, but we will also see that there are some stumbling blocks along
the way, which we'll have to apply our own thinking to, to solve appropriately.